well what does it mean to be truly
authentic and how does this idea of
authenticity impact what it means to be
whole or personhood and so like looking
at yourself how do you identify and how
is your identity your chosen identity
based on your conceptualization of what
it means to be authentically something
just like how you define authenticity
and your relationship to authenticity
impact how you choose to identify and
sort of as an extension of this and
these kind of go together that's why
we're seeing them together do the
languages or does the language that you
speak or that your ancestors spoke
affect this concept of awesome
authenticity so if you're the son of
someone whose parents spoke a language
but you don't speak it do you feel less
authentic or does it make you feel more
authentic in some manner or are their
linguistic discourses of power that
affect how you perceive the roles that
the languages that you speak or that are
your ancestors spoke affect your choice
of identity and how authenticity of my
language plays a role in it should be
presented the second question I think we
should start answering right so thank
you so much
[Applause]
[Laughter]
so I guess the first thing this so I'll
answer it 1 & 2 but I'll start with 2
because this is something that I always
think about is the fact that I don't
speak Spanish makes me less authentic
and whatever Hispanic or Mexican
identity I have because I'm not able I
feel like I wasn't allowed to identify
with the Hispanic or Mexican community
because I didn't speak Spanish and like
you know growing up I guess it was
different for my mother it didn't matter
to her and I guess at that time frame
you know whatever the population like
Spanish is becoming like a very profound
language in the US and so like maybe
during my mother's time like it you know
there weren't a whole lot of Spanish
speakers like for her it didn't matter I
mean like my grandmother growing up it
was like not okay for her to speak in so
I feel like it's different for my mother
because she doesn't care her I honestly
I don't know how I should ask my mom how
she identifies with herself but it's
very different because for me I do feel
like that was important whereas it
wasn't important for her and I still
don't feel authentic in my Hispanic or
Mexican identity because I don't speak
the language hmm and then maybe in some
ways speaking the language would give
what allow me to identify more with like
the culture because I feel like it's
important mm-hmm
and then I guess overall authentic I
honestly hate thinking of it like that
because I'm so unauthentic then because
I'm african-american I'm white and I'm
Hispanic and nobody considers me
authentic because it's like how can you
be authentic if being often I feel like
being authentic in this way means like
having to identify specifically with one
or another and like you can't
authenticate be more than one I don't
know if that makes sense and I guess for
me it's just like my identity like I
just had to pick and choose what I liked
what was okay
and some of it has been imposed on me
there are aspects of my identity that I
didn't get to choose and I'm trying to
change because like now feeling like
woke I guess I'm like learning about
different aspects of like my culture and
like history regarding you know whatever
it may be I feel like I'm trying to
change aspects of my identity that were
not yeah I hope questions I got really
flustered it's like there's this camera
over here candid here because I think
you mentioned the camera but this is not
live which means that what is no no no
but whatever you decide that you don't
want to be going to the billions we will
remove okay so okay so I want you to
feel totally comfortable that if you see
anything that you feel should stay in
the class here I think it's I think it's
okay we'll just we'll just edit it and
make sure that one thing that you have
to think about I mean which is actually
key so there are lots of other folks you
know even younger than you at least
you've you can step back and as you just
said you said okay now need to remove
that from my identity I mean to make
this choice I mean to think about what
was imposed to myself you see that so
how many people don't have this capacity
to actually step back and self analyze
what you just did you see so yeah but
that that's not you sharing with other
people that might help them a lot you
know because because it frees you to be
able to do that right it's it's a path
to freedom in a way self-liberation
at the same time because it's so hard to
you know because I think like some of
the things like some of these things are
so ingrained into society and like for
different people like how you see
yourself in the world and like it's
really hard change perception like for
instance like I've talked about the
super but like hair like
african-american hair and trying to
change my perception african-american
hair like relates in some ways to
changing perceptions of my own identity
because um I guess I I don't know I
think it's it's like kind of unfair not
nothing you guys cuz like we all do it
but like it's unfair to like use the
word authentic when referring to
something like identity or like culture
or like a group of people because it's
like I mean I don't think was a word
that was intended for like a person like
it's very much like one of those
adjectives it's like for inanimate
objects you know it's like fur it's for
things that like don't have yeah I feel
like authentic like something that you
can like go define like okay if
something is authentically gold that
means like 100 percent gold but like you
can't like put bounds on things like
people and cultures and identities to
the point where you have like a concrete
definition because no person's ever
gonna fit that perfect definition it's
always been the tendency to try to
quantize yeah so you mentioned gold
right so in the history of 80 there was
a famous French that he was Creole
French meaning he was a French ancestry
but it was politically anything it was
more Buddhist anything and yet one
chapter where he cleared his calculus of
it could compute 128 parts of blackest
is white so yeah this calculus of if you
have like a fire near me latitude if you
quarter
black but three-quarters white when you
walk to him and he had turns we had
adjectives talking about adjectives yet
adjectives for each of these categories
but but uh how do you compute that Oh
you how can you look at someone and
decide that the earth 102 what I wanted
to meet black receive the rest
why you see but it was his strong belief
that that you could do that and not
actually each of the of this partition
to define but guess it's alone logical
physics that if you were half black half
white would behave like this he would
have physical focus from behind but if
you were one quarter wife and three
quarters back and could predict what
your behavior and your physics let me
look like it's in think of Jim Crow in
the u.s. is one drop of black blood one
drop of black blood would make you
pretty good at people to take of it in
these terms and try to so I guess like
what I'm thinking about because I
remember you told this story like early
in the semester about how look there are
these documentarians from New York who
like came to like doing yes thank you
they were like felt bad cause like the
idea that like they were like
investigation for not speaking Haitian
Creole so like I agree that like the
idea of authenticity implies that
there's like this paradigm like way to
be an identity but so I don't know like
it's not clear to me that like it like
it seems possible that like the paradigm
patient does speak through although I
don't know
wonder about that I also feel like that
I agree with that statement however I
feel that maybe in the future it won't
be a possible paradigm just because it's
like migration and and and the fact that
like there can be a Haitian who is like
three generations away from that parent
that was Haitian and they're still
allowed to say that they're Haitian you
know they don't speak Creole they may be
I don't know have whatever you can
define as the paradigm Haitian so I
guess for now that might be a true
statement to a certain extent but I
don't think that but I think that that
was the point of the concept of us in
authenticity and we saw that see I'm
gonna mention at she be and what jungle
right because because they have a whole
debate about what an authentic African
right thing right and that's what is
actually part of a bigger conference
where they were debating what makes it
authentic yes the problem is like build
the line-drawing like oh you're not a
real patient yeah
like one thing I can
but like I like a lot of your examples
for like mixing different cultures and
like not bad not being on and take
anymore but one thing I really like that
you guys brought up was the idea of like
tracks and like especially when you said
about India where like when you think of
India there's like this one thing you
think of whether it's like a food or
like the culture and that's like very
North Indian it's not like I come from
South India and like if I like as I came
here I like chose to be more Indian like
I got more involved with like clubs on
campus and stuff like that but like I
feel like the Indian I'm becoming is
like very different than my actual like
yeah so like I I have all these like
connections or like cultures that I
think I'm like getting but it's it's
actually not really connected to my
family at all and I guess that's
partially because I don't speak the
language that they have so like none of
my culture came from like my family but
also by not by not speaking that
language like like everything about my
culture from home like whether it's
religion or anything like that is it's
kind of very separating for me so I like
guess I kind of understand it but I
don't really understand like the roots
of most of it whereas everything here
that I'm learning I'm like oh okay like
this make sounds like this is what
everyone does
in America okay so I think that that
goes back to your question right because
if you think of was now one of the
best-known Haitian writer if it was
danticat right that's that we've read in
this class and it wins okay see was in
Haiti until age 12 and a [ __ ] 12c came
to the you to Brooklyn New York in ashes
one of the best-known Asian writers and
she sees herself as education you see
and she speaks Creole which is a writing
career we see all of the text that she's
become famous for they are English text
feed but for me when I meet receptacle
as we did here in the class
I can hear hit yet cata fill Haiti so
she's managed to write as a Haitian
although she doesn't speak Creole you
see and and as she does so she's also
become a very powerful woman another
case is quite clear to John right you
guys know this hip-hop artists quite
well so what it has done so much for
Haiti back at some point it was it to be
he shan't pitted it yeah you know any
was because he was excluded from running
because he was not patient enough
legally he had spent too much time
authority but yet in what is one of the
best-known Haitians in the world today
the white children because it's major
hip-hop artist and he thinks must be in
English but he also has some songs in
Creoles actually plan to remind people
that mutation is the annual real funny
thing when he goes to a concert he wraps
himself of the Haitian flag if the so
it's very probation without having the
full inventory of what defines Haitian
base so I think aliquot you beautiful
salad area that you can create your own
in their identity in even a very cap and
that's what an attitude should do for it
should be an asset it should be the tool
Forest where the muscles in the world
not something that like to hold us back
and if you can delete feature on
serotype threat that the better way to
work actually so people were being
hindered in the performance because my
pain
see it's because of then being put in
the box because of that you see what you
guys are think that when we can use it
in the way that black white just said
well I'm going to create my own and be
powerful with it and be happy with it
you see not that other people put me in
the box and I think that's that's what
we should think about when people
imposing on us to describe you very
moving that we imposed a fantasy how you
want to do such a weak man eventually if
you do that well you you become happier
and like right hopefully
you